I want to think about not just this
series right but any geometric series
for which the limiting some exists
remember just like some limits exist
some limiting songs that don't exist and
we're going to dig into that a second
right so generally speaking how did we
define the sum the commercial song right
of a series up to the end of term how do
we define it for GP I'll give you a tip
it's a fracture hey I could have that
switch to ratify what which would mean I
would sit around the denominator which
is okay but as you'll see in a second
remember I said you know some series fit
this format and other series to fit the
other format you'll see pretty quickly
why I'm sure I've chosen this format
maybe for ease in it now what is what is
s the limiting some it's not this this
is the partial song right the living sum
is good right so I'm going to take that
limit so let's go limit as n approaches
infinity of this must be the limit as n
approaches infinity of that
okay now immediately you see just like
we saw with one two four eight right
that this isn't always meaningful you
don't always get an answer for this
because if your ratio is two for
instance right this term here out of the
end it's gonna blow up it's going to
happen
give us that problem we had before right
so we said we need some conditions on
our the ratio can only be certain things
right so we said that the ratio has to
be it can't be to copy one and a half it
can't even be one
it's very less than one right so I say
that okay now that's good what is not
everything right do you make the one we
were having a look at geometric means
geometric means and I said if I gave you
this series right there's a number you
can certain there that will make that a
GP right do you remember that what is
the genic GM of this particular signal
ah now you remember that in fact it is
not just one value it's to write plus
four make energy a GP that's the obvious
one but minus four is just as much of a
GP it has a M it has a relation of many
of - yes now let's just think about this
for a second well let's go for that
unusual place what's the next term all
right now think with me for a second
briefly about this example it's not just
you know four people controlling it's
actually very helpful for us what are
the partial sums what's going on here
what's the first partial sum what's the
second part
- - what's the song
okay now did I get it right yeah no
sixteen and then the fifth one I guess
would be 22 now tell me I had two
categories for different series right
convergent ones and divergent ones which
category is this it's just it's blowin
up is it if I were to graph this right
yeah I'd go 2 and then negative 2 and
then 6 and then negative 10 and then 22
it's doing something like this if
there's anything that's diverging that's
my magic okay so therefore R is less
than 1
well sorry these are less than negative
1 in this case Triton's are less than 1
in this case it is because negative 2 is
less than 1 right but it's blowing up so
I need to add something to this
condition it can't just be less than 1
it's also going to be greater than now
let's just not for a second if you're a
zero I think we're definitely safe we're
definitely safe right um you know a
tenth a quarter a fifth whatever they'll
all be fun they'll all be like this kind
of series right but other negative
numbers completely remember how I said
before there was this alternating series
I had right because JP's can do this
back and forth thing right let's just
look at this guy and imagine what would
happen if we were alternating this would
be - I guess I'd get a minus 1 over 16
yeah okay now it's that with the case
come on think with me this is all about
partial sums and what their limit is
okay so first partial sum the same
what's the second partial what's the
third partial sum
three days what's the fourth one this is
a behind take away a 16 it's a 5/16 on
these numbers converging to something
now I'm gonna leave this I'm gonna leave
this for you for a second
you we've time for values we've done it
by hand
okay I'll show you if you like I didn't
bring with me but maybe in period three
I'll bring my laptop spreadsheets up
good for this kind of thing we're gonna
do this by hand right is it like this
yes maybe if I do some decimals that
might help right
this is 0.5 this is 0.25 this is 0.375
yep what's 5 I've no idea is it
converging to something okay
so I'll let you ever think about this
but suffice to say for now okay actually
you'll be fine you'll be fine
as so long as you're between minus 1 and
1 you'll clear the K it will do it will
do what was suggested right you'll do
this like that ok you were still
converge to something yeah that's
learning fingers and R we have for you
so it's kind of that sure yours all
right which doesn't make a GP at all but
because it makes it even Michigan
already is most people ok now just one
more thing this will slightly ever so
slightly more concise way to write this
okay um if R is between negative 1 and 1
what we mean is that the size of R has
to be less than 1 the size of it cuz
like the size of negative 1 we still
call the size of that one like how far
is through you
now we have another name for size right
how big something is irrespective of its
sign irrespective in sight we call it
absolute value absolute value how big am
I
how far am i from the origin I want that
to be less than 1 and that includes the
negative 1 case ok so these two things
they mean the same thing
ok now by the way just before I I now
move on right do you see how much time
we invested to think about this thing
right we already talked about like most
something Long's and when we're doing
differentiation and so on conditions
restrictions on domain whatever they're
not enough to thought they're not at all
by the way just just have a think about
this these things are crucial to this
result if these are true that everything
I'm about to say is completely
ridiculous right the conditions really
matter the restrictions remember now
that I know what the restrictions are I
can do something with this thing right
let's think about it I said approaching
infinity and only appears once in this
term but I'm interested in right it only
appears once that are to the intern okay
so now if I can understand that are the
intern then the whole thing collapses
right so let's think of this way the
limit as n approaches infinity of just
that guy just that guy by himself
keeping in mind this condition this
condition all right and curly if this is
like say AHA like an L case right
that's this case here isn't it right as
n approaches infinity that thing is just
gonna vanish away the limit exists it's
zero okay with that so if R is a
fraction of some kind right like a
hopper third then this will be 1/2 to
the you know a hundred a half to the
thousand it's gonna vanish away okay
so even by the way even if it's like 99
over a hundred 99 percent it will take a
long time but if I'm going to infinity I
have all the time in the world I'll get
to zero okay all right so being at that
part is zero
now I don't need to do any other fancy
tricks I have a I have one take away
zero what I just need to establish I
want a way off one take my zero is one
so now I have this little result yeah
generally speaking this is the same
limiting sum that I got to fall but it
will give it to me not just for this
series but for any series that fits
these conditions okay let's just quickly
test it make sure it works with the
result that we got before okay the
example you just example we started with
what's the first term will take its what
am i dividing by 1 minus 1/2 the common
ratio 1 - uh-huh
1 minus 1/2 of course is just 1/2 1/2
divided by 1/2 that embed me once okay